las vegas quickly becoming a sports
mecca businesses are already looking to
a big event next year yeah the biggest
international racing event in the world
we're talking about formula one is going
to race on the strip in november of next
year madison kimbrough spoke to some
local businesses on the strip about what
this will mean for them
it might be over a year away but we all
know how fast time passes here in vegas
and according to formula one grand prix
take a look at the strip behind me this
takeover is going to take place from
november 16th to 18th on the las vegas
strip
we do hope that we get a lot of tourists
that haven't been to vegas try to run
with us
you know it's obviously they're not
going to be able to drive on the las
vegas strip track but they can cruise
around vegas and a nice ride that was
edwin manager of lvc exotics one of the
only exotic rental companies located
directly on the strip he says the
announcement of formula one coming to
las vegas next november has him pumped
for what it means for his business for
us it's going to be really good since we
specialize in exotic rentals and luxury
rentals
but it's just going to bring a whole
different demographic to las vegas and a
lot more tourists for us that we've
probably never seen before lvc exotics
getting a lot of their clientele through
walk-ins they currently have about 30
cars in their fleet many of which will
be similar to what's seen at formula one
for those unfamiliar with the
international racing event it's a four
day and night sports and entertainment
program with racing taking place
november 16th through the 18th and the
strip being completely blocked off for
it some managers of businesses located
on the strip say while it may be more
than a year away now is the time to
prepare
we do hope to sell out during that week
usually we sell out on the weekends but
it'd be nice to sell out during the
weekdays as well there's me a lot of
rush people are going to be coming
around the globe to look at this
speaking of car shows for those
qualified car fanatics the annual sema
show the trade only event for automotive
industry members that's going to take
place this november and that's going to
be right here at the convention center
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now